and i'm like oh y'all shutting this down
again yeah yeah
no it gets tiring man it gets tiring and
like listen now they're talking about
shutting down this place and i'm like i
get it
but [ __ ] i'm over it and you know what
from polls that have come out the
support for all these lockdowns have
dropped significantly because people
people like [ __ ]
bro you took your needle you said you
said what'd i say
not you but you said
they
we're getting back we're getting one
stab
two stab [ __ ] i got three doses i got
[ __ ] three doses you got three
of them i got it that's one dose
then i got the vacs that's two doses and
i got the second bags that's three doses
okay okay so you you mean the natural
immunity thing
it's the dose
fair point a lot of places are taking
that right so you thought you told
everybody and i was on that i was with
you how many more times oh everything
that i said was everything that i said
was i understand the people that i
understand the people that don't want it
rough i'm over but now
i'm over it we took the three stabs in
order for this [ __ ] not to happen so
basically we got stabbed for nothing
it's like for real they're really
positive that this third shot is gonna
help you
uh
your immune system and that you know
it's to be good for this variant so
let's hope that the fourth shot is
really going to help you so we're really
really staying positive and our mind you
know on focus for the fifth shot uh so
that by the sixth shot we really get in
line to
be able to accept the seventh shot and
uh so so that you know everybody and all
the body are able to
you know prepare for the seventh shot to
do
to eventually be able to have an eight
shot that is gonna be able to help uh
reconstruct and fortify your body for
the nine shot
and maybe by then maybe by then
maybe by then the tenth shot is gonna be
effective
and then
uh
like you know all those businesses are
gonna be able to you know uh enforce the
11th shot
i think we got it we got it do we need
to go for a 12 shot
bro we never know because you know by
the 12 shot
the 13 one is the lucky one
that maybe after the 14th shot it's
gonna work
uh we're staying positive we're staying
positive we're uh listen listen i got
tired of hearing your rants and that
didn't even happen okay
at this point i'm just i'm just done i'm
not gonna do nothing more i'm not gonna
take any extra shots i'm not doing that
and i'll just go to places where they
accept people who haven't had boosters
because i'm tired bro how how i'm tired
i can't do it it's not worth it they've
lost their [ __ ] minds
how is
uh little john and pitbull song ain't
making a comeback shot shot shot shot
shot shot shot shot shot shot shot shot
shot everybody
you know that's the vaccine ceo's doing
that dancing yeah they're up there in
their penthouses bro i'm leaving town
i'm out i'm just i'm just over it it's
just like brother at some point like i
can't work i can't have any consistency
everything comes in a way so i get even
with eighty ninety percent they still be
like new waves new
why because apparently these maxes
aren't affected they're not for
effectiveness
i give up
i give up just let it happen
but how many times we gonna shut down a
business like breath the effect that
this is having on people mentally and
physically is outstanding i can't i
can't do it i can't do it i can't do it
it's not a way to live i can't do it i
got friends who like lost their whole
livelihoods oh yeah yeah and they don't
know how they're gonna recover three
times
three times bruh our government said
reinvent yourself and i understand that
they ain't got to reinvent [ __ ] because
it just got to be the government you see
what i was saying
it's hard out here
it's hard out here bro now they're
talking about now they're gonna try to
make boosters mandatory and like
isn't that cool you don't know
yo yo trevor noah came out and said like
hey maybe we should take advice from the
ceos who are trying to tell us i think
we need the boosters like maybe i'll go
to somebody like a scientist before i go
to ceo of a drug company who says i need
their trust it's like how many more
times are we going to have to
to
don't have any
and when does it stop because look some
places are reasonable some places
haven't done the whole
fifth lockdown seventh lockdown here
they just shut it all down
your business tough luck [ __ ] your
livelihood tough luck and it's like
rough oh now we need new shots and we're
going to try to do experimental drugs to
find out if the new shots are going to
be very effective because it's like
i can't i can't be i like i have no good
points for you guys
i have no good arguments i have no
scientific stuff to say nothing i'm just
tired
i am absolutely tired and from what the
polls are showing people are also
[ __ ] tired and not interested anymore
[ __ ] that's it that's all
that's all they're not having it no no
it's not a way to live and i can
understand it's not a way to listen i
can understand it's just that whenever
we're going to come out of that
because now there's no like you know we
had to serb we have all that no the
government we don't got good government
handouts yeah they hung government yeah
you know the stemies yeah
no we don't have that anymore no so
that's shut down no [ __ ] is shut down
and it's just
man
man [ __ ]
[ __ ]
so
[ __ ] oh this [ __ ] was supposed
was supposed to be two weeks
yeah
no i'm out so if you guys don't hear too
much from us in january the reason why
is because we're out of town we taking a
break okay
cause this [ __ ] is dull as [ __ ]
there is his dad dead
he's dead
and it's been like this for two years
now
i'm done man how many lockdowns curfews
how many more that's my thoughts on that
i'm just so if you guys don't hear from
us in january you're wondering where we
are now you know what and and all those
comedians that were talking [ __ ] about
the people from the conspiracy
uh y'all old [ __ ] an apology
you've been talking [ __ ] but god damn
maybe they would onto something all the
late night talk shows
yeah yeah
very easy to isolate when you got
millions in the bank
it's very easy to just accept a lockdown
when you can uber eat whatever you want
it's like and also let's not kid
ourselves
rich people are not following these
rules you've got obama having full-on
birthday parties with 500-600 people
little parties for themselves like let's
keep it above it's not even that it's
just like it's just like please stay in
your home [ __ ] you got a theater in
your home
you got a gym in your home
you got a bowling alley you got a pool
you got a tennis court a basketball
court over it you got you can be in your
house never seen your significant other
in that house bruh
i mean it's easy for you to be like yeah
stay in your house you have a
multi-million dollar home boo-boo
of course you're gonna stay in your
house you got a popcorn machine in there
you don't even do your own laundry god
damn it
it's easy
evie
you got people that take care of your
kids god damn it them kids
they don't raise themselves by
themselves no you got helping hands for
that [ __ ] if you make a whole lot of
money and i got a big ass house shut the
head for don't tell people what to do i
came here on this day to tell the people
you need to do we need this we're not
together
in this we're not
we're not
we're not it's like you're ellen's uh
special relatable you're not of course i
was irony i understand i got that but
exactly you're not come on boo boo
you're not
stay home wearing this thing
shut up